from our previous interview shane we had
one video that had a lot of comments
that we were hoping to run by you and
maybe get some clarification on uh the
big reason why many people will never
have a career in the film industry and
so here's one comment sounds great in
theory but we literally can't afford to
spend our time not getting paid these
days honestly lol
i could
read another if you'd like okay okay
you can hustle be the quote johnny on
the spot and still fall through the
cracks starting out i worked on a ton of
projects for free as much as i could
living at home and later when i saved up
and moved to la but eventually those
resources run out and you have to pay
rent there's a definite class element to
being able to go out and spend two years
working for free nobody should work for
free
here's another one quick question if you
work on a movie 12 plus hours a day for
a month and you do that for a year or so
for free dot dot dot how exactly do you
pay rent question mark
okay here's another one
i've been working my tail
on
i'm gonna probably tail off he doesn't
think he's working the tail off they're
working their tail yeah
wax on wax off sorry okay um
i've been working my tail off on crappy
jobs outside the movie industry and i
cannot accept unpaid jobs inside the
industry because i have to eat and live
and that costs money i am a little
confused about this attitude of stanley
thanks that you are supporting such a
bad role model i'm a bad role model okay
god i feel bad that so much of this was
misconstrued and i don't blame the the
the viewers
and and i'd first like to apologize if
anything was misunderstood i i'm not
telling you to sell your soul work for
free live on the streets and not pay
rent
um let me clarify a few things with that
um
because i encourage you to get out there
and work and hustle and do what you have
to do to get on a set a lot of the sets
that you're going to get on cannot
afford you anyway
and they or they are already filled and
what my point was it doesn't mean you go
work 75 hours a week for free six days a
week on a film it means you make
yourself available to a producer or a
filmmaker and say look i have a job
i need to get time on a set can i put in
two days a week i'm off saturday and
tuesdays i'm off the weekend i'm off at
night and get yourself involved and in
the loop of people that are doing what
you ultimately want to do i'm not saying
that you've got to go you know live in
your car to go work for free i
personally worked for free a lot but i
also had other jobs just because i had a
father in the industry trust me it
didn't help me
in a way that a lot of people think it
might have when i when i decided that i
wanted to make a living in film the only
thing my father gave me was his rolodex
he said great
there you go you know some of the people
in there make some calls
i worked for hundreds of different
people before he hired me full-time i
wasn't until my mid-20s until i was
working with my dad full-time we had a
lot of success early on with his
documentaries and shows that he did we
did one every two years
i moved out when i was 18 i didn't have
my rent covered i was out hustling i
held odd jobs i sold cars i worked at
restaurants i waited tables i bus tables
you know i detailed cars i mowed lawns i
painted houses i did construction
i still found a way to get on a set
every week and put in my time to make
new contacts so
what i'm trying to encourage you guys to
understand is it's not going to come to
you
you have to make sacrifices i am not
asking you to yourself out and
work for free for everybody all the time
to start to get a track record as a
reliable resource on a set it's like
interning you know we have a lot of
interns that come and go on our shows
from films from film school that work on
our productions we we get them when we
can they get credit some of our greatest
regular
crew members that we pay are from
interns from college that came in and
worked for two or three days a week if
we were lucky during a production from
four years ago it's just to encourage
everybody to understand it's not coming
to you if it's not coming to you how are
you going to get something you know if
you want to get to an island it ain't
coming to you you either swim or take a
boat if you don't have money for a boat
you don't have the resources for a boat
get in water start swimming that's all
i'm trying to say it's to encourage you
guys to understand that's what i had to
do i brought up a friend of mine whose
father had two oscars his mother had i
think five or seven emmys
when he pulled his head out of his ass
and decided he wanted to work in the
film industry he told his parents his
plan assuming they would get him work
they said great dad picked up the phone
and i think he called deluxe which was
an old film color house back in the day
my friend was sweeping floors there for
two years before they let him sit behind
an edit bay
that was the job he got the first year
he was there he was there two or three
hours a day and he wasn't paid that's
just how it was back in our day if i
offend people of today's generation
because we actually worked for free and
earned our stripes by busting ass and
bringing our own lunch sorry you were
offended but that's how we did it
we still have people that want to intern
that show up we still have great people
that come in and say look i'd like to
give you a day on the set i want to show
you what i'm about because we're not
looking for the help we have the people
that are on the team so it's about
people coming to us and saying i want to
show you what i can do for you of course
we're going to feed you we'll water you
come on out for a few hours show us what
you got so when we make our next film we
know to call you and there's a lot of
filmmakers that are willing to do that i
used to call everybody i knew in that
rolodex and i called them and we didn't
have text and email it was phone calls
and it was you know hey phil hearn it's
shane stanley lee's son
yeah that one um listen i need to get on
a set do you need somebody to be a pa in
ac a second you know what can i do to
get on a set phil would call back
sometimes and say yeah if you want to
come work on saturday we're doing a show
with richard crenna come on out bring
your own lunch i'll i'll get you on the
set giant getting paid and i'd show up
you know i did that with steve elkins
phil hearn did that with uh ken shafer i
did that with with tom coster i did that
with with you know chad shoe cat i think
got me on a couple of shows
it it's just what we did and i i hope
and i understand times have changed and
all that but my my
heart and my spirit of telling you what
i did last time that ruffled some
feathers
was not sell your soul and work for free
for 70 hours a week do your
meet your responsibilities with your
paying job but we all don't work 70
hours a week for a paying job so you
find the time to get on a set even if
it's three hours a day and show people
what you got and be around people that
are doing what you love so they know
that they can call and rely on you that
was the sole purpose of that
why do you think um
younger generations have reacted
stronger than maybe
you know previous ones it's because a
lot of interns have been taken advantage
of yeah i think so i mean when you work
with interns you can't you can't replace
interns you can't replace employees with
interns and i think you know ever since
the big black swan lawsuit
that changed the dynamics you know we
work very closely with a lot of amazing
schools you know the lacc la vc uh we're
working with college of the desert this
year out in palm springs and uh pierce
college
and you know the rules are simple is is
you know
give the kids the opportunity
let them shadow and and our our guys on
our crew are so amazing with them
because they
they've been fortunate in their
upbringing and they understand what hard
work is they don't let the kids sit
around they're like hey grab an end of
that come on let me show you how to
clean a lens when we had interns
literally doing second ac duties for for
a film when we had a second ad
i'm sorry second ac and and to watch
these kids learn how to pick up these 60
or 70 thousand dollar lenses and clean
them and prep them and put them on the
cameras they're not learning that in the
classroom and i guarantee you they're
not learning that during a pandemic so
we're really big about interns coming
out and learning
various
jobs on the set you know we try to move
them to sound to camera to a.d
upm they come shadow me for a day they
can learn everything what not to do
you know go in a hair and makeup learn
how that is go learn wardrobe and how we
tag everything for the days and the
scenes and how sometimes wardrobe is
used for half of the day it's put away
we use it for an hour something else and
then we go back to that and just the way
the schedule is how we shoot
they don't learn these things in a
classroom
and
you know
[Music]
they're paying for an education that
that they get in a class and so when
they're able to come on a set with
filmmakers that are willing to open
their doors and their hearts to say come
learn
you know and that's that's what that's
that's the spirit of what i what i try
to to
you know
to encourage
you